hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
i don't think i smell that much?
today we're talking about armpit stink you
might have seen a lot of natural deodorants
on the market and you might have been
wondering do you really need to switch?
is there any truth to the idea that aluminium
is bad for you? this is the video for you
if you like nerding out about the science
behind beauty products click the like the
subscribe and click the nerdification
bell so you don't miss any videos
aluminium compounds are found in lots of
antiperspirant products and the main reason
they're in there is to stop you from sweating
as much and cut down on body odor these are
ingredients like aluminium chlorohydrate
these interact with water and they form
a plug in your sweat gland and so that stops
the sweat from coming out this plug comes out
naturally later when your skin cells shed
and this is what keeps your armpits dry
with body odor there are two main
ingredients that combine to make you stink
odor forming chemicals or odor precursors
that are found in some types of sweat
and the right kind of bacteria mostly
corynebacteria and also staphylococci
basically larger molecules can't evaporate
as easily so they can't make it to your nose
where you can smell it in fresh sweat the
odor molecules are part of a larger molecule
they need the bacteria to come along and chop off
the odor molecule to free it and then it can drift
off into your nose and make you stink
so without the bacteria the sweat won't
smell and without the sweat the bacteria
has nothing to chop up and cause stank
the aluminium based plugs block the sweat
and so there's less fuel for the bacteria to
turn into odor it also makes your armpits less
damp and so it's a less friendly environment
for bacteria to sit around and poop out
stink so overall these aluminium salts
are a super effective way of cutting
down on stink but like with any other
unnatural sounding ingredient there's been
a lot of fear-mongering around aluminium
i think this is the scariest claim that
aluminium is linked to breast cancer
but pretty much all reputable
sources says there's no link
so the canadian cancer society says there is
no evidence that the use of antiperspirants
increases your risk for breast cancer there is
no link between aluminium and breast cancer risk
the american cancer society says
there are no strong epidemiologic
studies in the medical literature
that link breast cancer risk
and antiperspirant use and very little
scientific evidence to support this claim
cancer research uk says there is no good
evidence that aluminium in deodorants
could increase the risk of
cancer in animals or humans
the national cancer institute says no scientific
evidence links the use of these products to the
development of breast cancer no studies
to date have confirmed any substantial
adverse effects of aluminium that could
contribute to increased breast cancer risks
in late 2019 the european commission's
scientific committee on consumer safety
re-evaluated aluminium antiperspirants and
again they concluded that they were safe
in the amounts used in cosmetics
so that's around six percent in
non-spray antiperspirants and ten
percent in spray antiperspirants
a number of scientific reviews over the years
have found that there's no clear evidence
that using aluminium antiperspirants
increases the risk of breast cancer
the 2008 review made a very bold statement
after analysis of the available literature
on the subject no scientific evidence
to support the hypothesis was identified
and no validated hypothesis appears likely to
open the way to interesting avenues of research
so if you've ever interacted with scientists
you'll know that it takes a lot for a scientist
to say there is absolutely nothing and even more
to make a scientist say that there is no point in
further researching a topic so where did this
myth come from and why does it keep persisting
if you've been following any sort of
ingredient fear mongering in beauty or
anywhere else you'll know that this is usually how
it goes an in vitro study suggests a possible link
the conditions in the in vitro study didn't really
reflect the reality of how that ingredients used
people ran with it anyway large-scale
population studies didn't find a link
but no one cares anymore because
everyone is already freaking out
so here's the evidence for aluminium being linked
to breast cancer firstly breast cancer tumors are
usually found near the armpit breast cancer
tumors are usually found in the upper outer
quadrant of the breast that's right next to
the armpit and so people started wondering
if some of the so-called unnatural things
we used in our armpits could be linked
a more likely explanation that most medical people
point out is that there's simply more tissue
in that area the quadrants aren't all evenly
sized and so if you have more cells in the upper
outer quadrant that's where you're more likely
to find cancer more cells means more cancer
secondly aluminium has had effects on
cells in in vitro studies some in vitro
studies have found that aluminium can
affect how estrogen receptors function
since the hormone estrogen has been found
to increase the growth of breast cancer
this could be interpreted as evidence that
aluminium could be linked to breast cancer
aluminium has also been found to damage dna in
cells but there are a lot of reasons why these
in vitro results don't translate to how we use
antiperspirants on our skin for aluminium to
have effects on living cells it would have to
be absorbed into your skin at a high enough
concentration but the aluminium salts used in
antiperspirants don't absorb well into skin
at all one study estimated that only 0.012% of
the applied aluminium actually absorbed into skin
most of our exposure to aluminium is actually
through food and it's estimated that the amount
that you get from antiperspirants versus the
amount that you get from food it's about 2.5
percent so there really isn't a lot more aluminium
in your body if you're using an antiperspirant
the study that found the dna damage used a
really high concentration much higher than you'd
ever find in the body in standard tests aluminium
didn't have any effect on cancer-causing mutations
another piece of evidence that gets brought up
is that aluminium concentrations are higher in
cancer tissue sometimes so some studies
have found that there's high aluminium
in breast cancer tissue but other studies
haven't found this association in a really
famous 2007 study there were 17 cancer
patients and they examined their breast
cancer tissue the aluminium was slightly
high in the outer region but they didn't
compare it with other parts of the body or
with people who didn't have breast cancer
a 2011 study found higher aluminium in nipple
aspirate from women with breast cancer than
those without a 2013 study looked at breast
tissue from people with breast cancer and they
didn't find any difference in aluminium between
the cancerous parts and the non-cancerous parts
other scientists have also mentioned
that maybe breast cancer tissue just
collects more aluminium than other tissue
this happens with some other substances
so what do the human studies tell us the best way
to check if something causes something in humans
is by looking at actual humans and the more of
them you have the better a 2002 study compared
about 800 women with breast cancer and 800 women
without and they found no link between breast
cancer risk and the use of antiperspirants or
deodorants a 2003 study looked at questionnaires
from about 400 women with breast cancer they
found that women who used antiperspirant and
deodorant and shaved their armpits had an earlier
age of diagnosis but some other experts have
pointed out some problems with this study that
would limit how we can interpret the results
so for example we didn't look at how often
women without breast cancer used these products
it could also just be saying that women who
use a lot of deodorant tend to be younger
a 2006 study compared 54 women
with breast cancer and 50 without
and they didn't find that the women with
breast cancer used antiperspirants more
but they did find an association with family
history and the use of oral contraceptives
so based on all this evidence it doesn't
seem like there's much of a link between
using antiperspirants with aluminium and getting
breast cancer in humans with real world usage
so why is the link between aluminium
and breast cancer so persistent
a number of cancer experts and institutions
have pointed out that it is one particular
research group who keeps on researching
the supposed link between aluminium and
breast cancer and this is despite other
scientists saying that the link is pretty darn
unconvincing to the point where it's not
really worth investing more resources into
studying it this group is the darbre group
you might remember them as the people who
started the fearmongering about parabens based
on a really flawed study their publications on
aluminium keep on emphasizing the in vitro
evidence even though other studies strongly
indicate that these in vitro studies don't
translate to what actually happens in humans
it's really hard to be convinced
that there is a link between
aluminium and breast cancer there are
glaring issues with experimental design
over a lot of the studies that have
supposedly found a link and if you study
something enough you'll inevitably find
correlations that will support your case
it's comforting to think that we can be completely
in control when it comes to whether or not you get
a disease but the reality is a lot of the time
it's completely arbitrary or out of our control
it's impossible to say what exactly caused a
particular case of cancer and it's usually not
very helpful either a lot of people who have
all of the risk factors for cancer never end
up developing cancer i'm sure we all know someone
who smoked continuously and never got lung cancer
but it can be useful to know the risk factors so
that you can improve your chances against cancer
we know that breast cancer risk is mostly
associated with things that are outside of
our control some of these are being female being
older being caucasian having a family history of
breast cancer certain genetic factors menstruating
before age 12 and having menopause after age 55
never having given birth being older when you have
your first child and having dense breast tissue
there are also some environmental and lifestyle
factors that are more within our control that are
also linked with breast cancer sedentary lifestyle
so not exercising much poor diet drinking alcohol
being overweight having ionizing radiation in the
chest area and having hormone replacement therapy
these lifestyle factors are generally a lot harder
to change than just switching your deodorant
so the narrative that such a simple change can
significantly help us against something as scary
as cancer is really alluring even though
the scientific evidence just doesn't add up
and unfortunately this sort
of convenient lie can make
us a bit complacent and not act on the
things that we should actually be acting on
there are a few other myths about why you
shouldn't use aluminium but here's the reality
not sweating is actually fine there's a myth that
because antiperspirants block sweat then it stops
your body from getting rid of toxins but your body
mostly gets rid of toxins through your kidneys
they put into pee or your liver which puts it into
your poop sweating plays an incredibly minor role
the main function of sweat is just to cool
you down not to actually flush out toxins
and you are sweating on the rest of your body
anyway there's no reason why the toxins have
to come out through your armpits sometimes this
myth also involves some talk of lymph nodes so
lymph nodes in your armpits are supposedly
important for clearing toxins and the aluminium
stops them from working but the lymph nodes
aren't actually connected to your sweat glands
so there are some valid reasons for
avoiding aluminium if your skin is
sensitive to aluminium if they cause a
rash then obviously you shouldn't use it
if armpit sweat isn't a problem for you
then there's no reason for you to use it
if antiperspirants aren't working well enough
for you then maybe you should look at other
options like perhaps botox injections if
you have incredibly poor kidney function
then you might want to avoid extra aluminium
you'll be doing this in your diet as well
if you're about to go for a breast screen
then your doctor might tell you to avoid
using aluminium but the reason for this
is that it can show up on images and
make them confusing to interpret it's
not because it's causing breast cancer
so i hope you like this video if you did give it
a thumbs up and you can subscribe to my channel
leave me a comment letting me know
what other myths you want me to bust
you can follow me on instagram
and check out my blog for more
on the science behind beauty products and
i'll see you next time to nerd out more
epidemiologic epidemiologic epidemio logic